if x is on the verge of collapse this
may play out poorly for him but I do
think the richest man whose net worth is
currently as of today estimated $244
billion I kind of think he can stand to
lose $44 billion and it's not just that
hold on like the there's investors
involved they would lose out of money
but let's look let's what's the worst
case scenario Elon says all the
advertisers pulled off in a cordinated
fashion for seeming the political
reasons you can't hold me responsible
for that X is now done what do we do
open source decentralizes our best path
to maintain the platform and retain
memberships and and advertising the me
the uh the Fede is great although if
they stay centralized on like big data
centers or in in AWS or Cloud wherever
they're hosting that can still get shut
out of the the fediverse so you're
looking versus a mesh Network yeah mesh
networks which are like really up and
coming and they're challenging still to
transmit video because they're you know
cell phone to cell phone but you have 50
cell phones 48 of them go down the other
two are still connected with Twitter